the PlayStation Vita is a remarkable
gaming handheld even two years after its
debut but Sony is beginning to rapidly
phase out the old design in favor of a
refined slimmer Vita in many ways it's
an overall improvement and unlike the
first version it comes bundled with a
free memory card in a free copy of
Borderlands 2 on paper it sounds like a
great value but even though there are
numerous improvements to the hardware
and some free extras sacrifices have
been made along the way and you may find
yourself weighing the benefits of both
models if you're considering picking up
the so called Vita slim the original
Vita is a strong piece of hardware but
it has its share of issues that needed
to be addressed the battery life is
great in standby mode or during gameplay
it typically taps out around the four
hour mark the lackluster battery
performance was also compounded by the
system's proprietary charging port it
negates the viability of common USB
cables and requires a USB port with a
data connection in order to accept a
charge common wall chargers won't cut it
plus it won't charge over USB if the
battery is completely dead it has to be
plugged into a wall socket thankfully
the new Vita resolves some of these
issues you no longer need a special Vita
only cable with the new micro USB port
and you don't need to rely on finicky
port restrictions either plus the
battery in the new Vita is reported to
last longer despite having the same
battery capacity while it's good to see
that the Vita's new screen doesn't
negatively impact battery life it altom
utley has a negative impact on the
overall experience the most notable
difference of the new Vita
is the use of an LCD panel versus the
old Ola D panel used in the original
sure LCD panels are cheaper to produce
which allows Sony to shave off a few
dollars from the Vita price tag but with
the persistent backlight colors look
washed out on the LCD panel compared to
the old version if you've used the
original Vita in any capacity you know
how impressive the O LED display can be
in the moment you look at the new one in
action you instantly recognize that it
fails to produce images that are as
crisp or vibrant if you've never used
the old model the shift in screen
technology won't stand out as much but
you also won't find the display on the
new Vita particularly impressive either
if anything its unremarkable still you
can find improvements in other areas
that make the new Vita an attractive
proposition the new USB port is one but
if you look around you find that the
buttons have also been improved
especially the start select and
PlayStation Home buttons these three
buttons were previously ovoid and sat
flush with the surface making them
unusually difficult to press now they
are represented like any other button
they're circular and raised up making
them far easier to press down especially
when you're trying to take screenshots
by pressing the start and home button at
the same time the new Vita also comes
with one gigabyte of built-in memory
which means that you don't have to have
a memory card in order to store a PSN
account and play games but oddly you
can't use the internal storage and the
included a gigabyte memory card at the
same time finally the new Vita is
slimmer and lighter than the old model
when viewed head-on the two versions
appear to have similar dimensions but
angle the system and you'll notice that
the new model is 20% slimmer it's less
bulky overall and it weighs 15% less in
the original Vita model there's no
getting around the fact that the new
Vita has an inferior screen compared to
its predecessor but it's easy to
appreciate the reduction in size weight
and price plus the changes made to the
USB port and the buttons make it a much
friendlier system to use overall even
though they won't look as good the same
games that worked on the old Vita work
on the new model so at the end of the
day it's worth considering for all of
its advantages